Peter Desberg, Author/Screenwriter: So should we be choreographing our leg
thing here? Jeffrey Davis, Author/Screenwriter: I like to do this. Film Courage: Well you
know you're each your own separate even
though you share sort of one mind for
the writing you're each your own
pursuits as we do whose mind are we
sharing neither of ours if I were
sharing his mind you see the
perforations on my wrist what is it
well you you're your own people for this
interview well don't you just do
whatever you want so actually we'll
we'll start with you then Jeffrey how
did you break into television no well
let's see a lot of this is gonna get cut
right edited and I think as long as
there's no names that are implicated
that's okay
well the way I broke into TV is that you
know my father my uncle my first
stepmother and my stepfather were all in
the industry so I grew up around it and
that meant I knew pretty much everybody
and not a single one of them gave me a
job
at first Peter laughs of my jobs I met
my first job was delivering call sheets
at Paramount which of course we don't do
anymore because everything is sent by
email then one of my dad's writing
partners it's a guy named Al Levitt his
real name was out Levitt he was
blacklisted he and his wife were
blacklisted and they wrote under the
name of Tom and Helen August and many
years later when the blacklist was over
and my dad was gray listed which meant
you were associated with yeah I don't
think I've told the story before that if
you were gray listed you were at some
point probably gonna be called before
the committee Wow
but his friends the levites after the
blacklist was over they were working on
an errand boy that's a long story
they were working on a Aaron Spelling
show it was the period when Love Boat
was on which I later worked on and
Fantasy Island and they wanted to do a
show called I think Aaron has sold a
show called Paradise Hotel
those days they would give you the pilot
script and six episodes and then they
would decide whether they were gonna
shoot it they didn't always shoot the
pilot so they gave me the script I had
never written television before I had I
think I tried to write a screenplay in
college not grad school because I was
going to be the great American novelist
and I got paid for it I got in the
writers guild and then ABC decided not
to make the show and that's was my first
job and then I met my writing partner my
long-term writing partner who had a lot
in common with because her uncle's and
her grandfather were the Fleischer
brothers so Popeye Betty Boop out of the
inkwell and we worked together 12 years
and that's the partnership that
Hollywood likes the best is male female
partners next they like partners because
they like to beat him they're getting
two minds for the price of one works so
that's sort of my background but I was
around it all my life and and why that
was a long-winded even by my standards
you can cut around it up here Peter for
you a joke writer when did you begin or
maybe that wasn't the yesterday well
surprisingly I came in from the academic
side and started studying the psychology
of humor and started doing research in
it and then I took some courses and
comedy writing and stand-up and got more
and more immersed and next thing you
know I was writing joke books we wrote a
few kids joke books they sold pretty
well and then started writing nasty or
adult joke books and fun stuff and you
have as long as good as stories Jeffries
well you also leave that as long you
also balance
your career moonlighting as a therapist
or psychologist well I started out as a
research psychologist later switched
over to or added clinical psychology to
it where actually here's another note
series of boring stories as Geoffrey
started the tradition I I developed a
course called instructional humor which
was a course for public speakers and how
to use humor to get their point across
and in doing that I watched how nervous
students would get when they had to get
up and deliver anything is how I get
interested in stage fright okay
interesting is there is there room for
jokes when you're doing clinical
research amongst the colleagues or
that's where you got your material from
interestingly stories help people
remember things when I was a professor
anything I wanted students to remember I
had to come up with a clever or funny
example or clever funny story to get
them to remember the concept otherwise
so it's a it's a survival skill the way
the mind works they'd remember stories
better than facts Oh interesting
so I'm sorry I was just saying that
explains about history and science for
me sorry have either of you tried
stand-up I think I remember you yes you
had my actually my first writing partner
Julie Fleischer had been in I don't know
you guys came here too late but the the
Kentucky Fried theatre was sort of the
thing of the moment and they did improv
shows which were scripted actually I
found out later and then they would do
some improv with the audience and they
were there their parents take them the
the guys who made went on and made
airplane later sucker Abrams there were
cousins and brothers the suckers
brothers
she and she went to work for them and
had long been an actress when I met her
she had been an actress and a stand-up
and one night she did convince me to go
to the to the comedy store and I it was
really bad I mean there's a channel
we're asking for their money back
doesn't get worse than that no I had I
have no I wanted to be an actor when I
was in high school and I remember doing
I don't think I've told you this story I
think I was doing inherit the wind which
is you know the two main characters are
are based on William Jennings Bryan and
Clarence Darrow and they both have these
long speeches and I didn't remember
memorize the speech from the Bible and I
went up halfway through it and drama
teacher said maybe not yeah I I think I
became a rut I think writers are very
often people who fail at everything else
so that's been my experience that you
know I did try a lot of other things and
yeah I or maybe they're comfortable in
their own element though that's a whole
nother type is despite the fact that I
love to be around people I love being
alone in a room and I think you have to
have that too so you know Peters much
more sociable than I am so he's good in
crowds I remember taking a stand-up
class and the first day the instructor
got up and said comedy is a really
aggressive art form you can't take it
get out it's kind of stuck with me hand
the cup of times I got up there and
tried it I said hmm
harder than looks on TV but my wife
plays the accordion and we have a we
play in a group together and I get to
write the songs and genres that
accordion plays with an attempt to make
them
funny and I get to do all the patter
between there which satisfies my need to
do that okay but again you feel
comfortable behind a typewriter or or
computer is it I as we say in Hollywood
I go both ways yes I I'm not sure how to
answer that
your new book that just came out is now
that's funny
and I understand that it's 24 writers
and you give them a premise like a
situation about a mother and daughter
and instead of asking them about their
process because I understand you say
that's the fastest way to get fiction
from an artist is to ask them what their
creative process is well you know when
you interview somebody and you ask them
about their process you have no idea
what you're getting and a lot of people
sort of romanticize the way they wish
their process was some will tell you
what they think they do but the easiest
way to get at it the most direct ways to
say do it and we'll watch and these
people were so nice about letting us do
that
and one of the things that we thought
was really interesting is the people we
had had major credits I mean these were
people who were show runners a lot of
these were show creators and all of them
at one point or another said what kind
of nervous doing this because we have
one shot at this
and then we're going to be compared to
our really really famous peers who might
do a better job and we want to you when
it's time did you give them to work out
this premise as much time as they the
the average interview was anywhere from
about an hour to two hours or so and
that was it they had a shot what you're
reading in the book is a liberally had
edited so we were very sure the most
important thing to us was the the
premise making because you get twenty
four different stories from this one
premise and but great questions come
out of it too but the most important
thing that we were sure not to cut was
the was the the premise work and I think
it it comes across and then the little
stories that we tell the little what do
you call them I was forget what you call
them well I mean we tried two sidebars
we we try to put some of our own
insights into it when we saw something
and every once in a while we'd see
something really unusual we'd see trends
like a surprisingly large number of the
writers had graduate degrees in math and
science as I mean that's weird for
comedy writers and one of the things
that we found interesting is
particularly for TV comedy writers
people in a room they tend to be more
story guys or joke guys and the science
math guys almost exclusively story guys
they were well organized and they were
really good at plotting a lot of the
people we we interviewed also had
stand-up backgrounds and they tended to
be much more surprisingly the joke guys
I think there was one funny story that
Lucien Eider who wrote for Everybody
Loves Raymond told us a story that he
was they were sitting around the table
and one of the guys grabs him and pulls
him under the table and he says pitch
this joke for me just pictured yourself
he says no no you've done stand-up I
wanted to make sure this gets in you'll
tell her better than me so people
knowing their skillset and and you know
what if we were to give you a premise
our own premise I'm curious how the two
of you would work it out it would be
brilliant I mean I'm pretty sure it
would be it would take a couple hours it
would okay he did I'm you know he feel
free to correct me but my observation is
that I've talked about this a lot with
my students because the good way to go
out of a university especially as an
undergrad is with a partner they are
much more likely to hire you as a
partner when you're young and help you
develop your craft then as a solo writer
I'm talking about comedy now I don't
know
dramaworks but I'm pretty sure that
there's so much cross-pollination now
it's the same but the way Peter is it's
too great I got way away from the story
I I don't know what talk to my own today
I have no idea
i I I believe that it is really a bad
thing for people to have the same skills
when their partner says this goes toward
answering the premise question you have
if both people in the partnership have
the same skills I don't see a reason for
the partnership complementary skills
Peter is he has two things one drives me
crazy he is able to put anything down as
a draft he has no blocks how he can even
call himself a writer without blocks is
shameful but he'll just put it down
knowing it's awful it's not ever as
awful as he thinks it is and then he'll
say to me can you work on this and
develop it so whereas I would rather
have dental surgery than do a first
draft it's painful for me but I love
rewriting and Peter is is capable of
seeing structure in his head I think
this comes in part from his science
background I'll start anywhere in the
story and just let it write itself and
both of those ways of working on
developing a premise or anything else
are valid you know the one thing we've
learned from this book is there isn't
any one way to do it I don't know if I
answered your question but I liked my
answer I have a little blabbermouth
going on today is that sort of answer
the question if we haven't gotten to it
yet the question but but I will throw in
one other my partnership one other sort
of interesting thing that we'll get to
it'll be for play for the question oh
good which is yesterday was only there
was a really there was a really huge
study on creativity done at Berkeley
years ago and it wasn't just creative
artists there was
architects doctors also it's also all
across fields and the two major findings
that they came out with were creative
people or have a better ability to
tolerate ambiguity and really important
they have the ability to suspend
judgment and one of the things you find
particularly with young writers is
they'll write something then they
immediately get depressing it's not
great it's not good enough right one of
the things and one of the things that
that we've learned and that for sure
helps me is I want to get something down
we again like the the old Hemingway
quote right drunk at its sober so once
you get something down then you have
something to work on and I've never
written anything that looks at the end
like it started out at the beginning so
I don't I don't feel constrained about
writing anything cuz I know it's gonna
get reshaped retool reworked yeah I
don't have that
I think the ability to be able to do
that is why the partnership works
because I can't do that at all I suffer
over my drafts and there's still first
drafts I mean I've never written
anything that even after fifteen drafts
I don't think could be better when I
have what Peter has taught me to do is
to move on and that's so now finally got
him to be more careful no I'm just so
finally an answer to your question yeah
I knew we'd get there eventually I
joined this this is foreplay this is my
patient is now if you gave us a premise
we would eagerly take a shot at it
knowing that where we started would not
be the place where it ended and it was
particularly fascinating in the book
when we had teams working where they
would just one would start riffing and
the other would just pick it up and then
the other would go back with and they'd
just go back and forth right well they
would they would change the sex they'd
say we don't know anything about mothers
and daughters but fathers and sons we
know a lot about so let's let's make it
a father and son or in one case my
favorite interview they the grandparents
are just lightly mentioned in in in in
the premise loo-loo Neider made it a
story more about the grandparents and
the mother and then the daughter the
daughter kind of got lost in it so you
know that's the other thing is I think
that the book does something that I've
never seen a book do before it
replicates not because of us because of
the writers it replicates what a writers
room would be like because a writers
room you come in you you you might have
the arc of the season you might have
those things but you need episodes along
that line and they'll pitch an idea in
somebody go that's not gonna work or we
did that three years ago or blah blah
blah whatever it is but ideas come in
the room and as Peter said they are not
the same at the end as when they stir
now I'm going to take us back to your
question sure um when Jeffrey and I were
starting
we we took a slightly academic view one
day and said what's your prediction
about the approach they're going to take
are they going to go more four-story
were they gonna go more for character
and we found out the answer is neither
they went for conflict and so if you
were to give us a premise to develop the
very first step we would take is okay
whatever the premise is where do we get
conflict out of it okay if there are two
characters involved how can we make them
butt heads to do something because
everything would come out of that can I
present my proposed premise okay so it's
two men both of them are under the age
of 40 their forties you know they're
they're getting near their so now I'm
giving is something we have no
relationship to whatsoever okay I can
remember so they're brothers and so we
have Adam who had a successful career
I'm not quite sure what he was doing but
his lifestyle caught up with him he had
a lot of money a lot of beautiful women
who were at his beck and call but it
kind of caught up with him and so he's
decided to he's decided to downsize his
lifestyle and change his mindset so he
meditates a lot of carrot juice a lot of
spiritual books and so he's living in a
rent-controlled Santa Monica apartment
really nice place and then his brother
Evan needs a place to stay for a little
bit now evan has had a little bit of a
gambling issue and tends to have his own
pharmacy in his bathroom so he's got a
little bit of you know some kind of a
recovery issues that he's still working
on but Evan needs a place to stay and so
he asked to stay at the rent-controlled
Santa Monica apartment but it interferes
with Adams peace of mind and then it
turns out this rent control apartment
may be turned into a condominium and so
these different developers need to see
the place so we have Adam who's he's
working by the way for a nonprofit which
he gets 1/4 of what he made but he likes
it he feels like he's making a
difference and Evan would like to get a
job there too because he needs money
like a loan shark that he needs to pay
back and they don't really like him at
the nonprofit he's kind of loud he's
kind of boisterous he says like
off-color things it's probably not the
right yeah yeah yeah he hasn't kind of
learned you know taco a quick question
sure Adam made all this money does he
still have it tucked away someplace oh
you know because okay if he downsized
and he was really serious about it and
donated all the money to PETA that would
be a very different script than if you
put that all away saying someday you
know I may want to go back or I may want
to find a cause that's worthy and it's
in there making money for me or it's no
I'm living this is the new dream I don't
want to have any encumbrances I don't
want to know I could fall back on money
I want to face life every day they'll
make a big difference in the script
interesting I hadn't thought about what
his bank account look like well that's
why we have these talks okay that's good
yeah so okay so that's part of what we
get to play with him okay great he's
bankers already you could start to see
the conflict if Evan knew that Adam had
this money tucked away but refused to
use it so he's constantly trying to find
ways to trick a demand to loosening the
purse strings a little bit so he's
trying to constantly scam his brother no
really this this money is going to go to
to help young blind orphans from from
Kenya who are secret away by this
terrorist group and we're trying to get
them out and so you're not going to deny
these kids are you and I have a I have a
secret contact and so if you just give
me some money I can let me so every day
there's a new scam right away you have a
built-in source of conflict I also think
what Peters talking about is about being
sorry I touched my mic good
I think you you have to develop the
world there's an old expression that
comes from real esque which I don't
think I've shared today please keep your
clothes on
there there was when the comedians would
come out on stage they needed to give
the backstory or exposition and so they
would say and there'd be a scrim of
Seville Spain and they would say so a
little Abbott would say the Costello
here we are in sunny Spain so the
audience would right away be oriented
and I think I think that to write
material name a comedy premise you have
to show them the world that exists at
the time so would this be this could be
a premise pilot which means that we see
the one brother the sort of mere do well
rather moving in or could be a or it
could be at what we call a mid slice
praten pilot which we learned all about
when we were when we were working on now
that's funny
and a mid slice is just it's the world
ongoing you already in the world
they're already together for a while and
later you could see the backstory and
how it happened
if I were developing this premise for
real I would try to make the brothers
even more different because what you've
got is a basic Odd Couple promise and I
mean you know I'll talk to anybody for
as long as they'll let me about Neil
Simon and what he did for comedy and how
he pushed that type of comedy forward
and you can see how many people he
influenced there's I mean Grace and
Frankie is basically an odd couple shove
you've seen it on Netflix it's amazing
mom which is a big hit that's an odd
couple situation two and a Half Men is
basically The Odd Couple with a kid so
this is kind of an odd couple' situation
but but in the Charlie Sheen Jon I was
blown his last name who was the other
brother it never helps Peter
otherwise salivated yeah the brother was
very uptight and straight and Charlie
Sheen was kind of I was thinking that it
made no sense it was it was kind of out
of character for the the uptight brother
the one with the money
to be the guy that had girlfriends at
his back unless you could make that
believable to me but that the other
brother didn't know how to treat women
I'm not saying that's the way it would
necessarily go but at least you'd be
because unless you have characters who
were very very different and very very
specific you don't have conflict now
again when we when we interviewed Yvette
Bowser
she was great because she said when I
start I have a whole list of traits and
I take each of my characters and I run
through were they politically they left
are they right where are they
financially they conservative the
gamblers what kind of music do they
listen to what kind of so again as we
take these two characters you know my
first bent is what were their folks like
was one more like mom was one more like
dad is that a never-ending source of
conflict between him or dad always like
you better or mom always like so all of
these things go into making up their
characters and then the trick is going
to be how to not make them to you know
dimensional the carrot brother is always
good and always nice and the other
brother is always trying to scam and
always nasty so so the scamming brother
has to have a couple of things that he
does that are really wonderful and nice
or charitable and the other guy has to
everything and when nobody's looking
maybe then he takes a little extra bosco
when nobody's looking and puts it into
his carrot juice something where they
become a little more humanized you said
you're saying you won't make them
3-dimensional yeah and and so again but
the jokes are going to come out of
dimensionalizing the character and so
each time you have a situation
we know we're just talking about this
before today
it said the the Charlie Peters concept
again that when you have a third object
so he gave us an example in the book of
this concept called a third object and
the example he gave us was the deer is
on a hill is a deer in the hill and it
said in Beauty and the Beast and now do
you visit aversion and beauty looks Anna
said oh what a cute little deer and the
Beast is salivating Saint dinner and so
that you see the two takes of the same
object and then all of a sudden you've
totally differentiated the characters
without having to describe them you see
it in the reaction so again as each
thing happens you know they find the
wallet on the street with money in it
and one is saying well how much did we
get the other says how can we find we
swallow it this is so taking each event
that happens and then you're constantly
seeing the two of them taking a totally
different look through the way we
dimensionalize their characters one more
little piece of information to our
scenario is that Adam who's mister you
know meditator and you know reads a lot
of Rama daus and he's just very
spiritual he used to date a woman who
was a model who he's you know since lost
contact with and their lifestyles are
totally different well unbeknownst to
him the other brother meets this model
at a bar and Adam comes back from his
nonprofit and they're both sitting on
the couch watching TV so he's met the
ex-girlfriend right first thing I would
say that is what my father taught me
which is you've got to make it
believable particularly and I said
that's even more true today in the in
the post Mary Tyler Moore post Cheers
post Fraser world which were little
Fraser was a satire but it was still
real and yet in the interim we still
have these crappy sitcoms that makes no
sense so but the really good sitcoms the
people are believable there's a
difference between believable
and reality if I the first thing I would
change is I wouldn't have them mad at a
bar I'm gonna bark because right away
I'm saying that's a little easy if they
went to a charitable event yeah
then it's plausible to have they'll be
there and then the brother happens to
hit on her and they click a little and
he's got to react to them but again
Jefferies made it plausible I do I see
the other note I would add is I would
have the the charity the charity the
brother who meditates and gives money to
cheer me you know maybe he runs a
foundation maybe he's not living in a
small apartment maybe it's not wearing
control that feels like a different show
to me this is what happens in a room
this is yeah what happens in a room
except you're there 12 to 14 hours and
the food is usually lousy but you know
and you're not serve anyone who you're
serving depending on who the showrunner
the least you could have done for these
people is serve lunch or drinking their
water but I think that what they knew is
again it's back to Peters thing I don't
I tell students all the time
please don't get hung up and protective
of the first idea you know develop it
feel good about hitting blind alleys
because that means you're making
progress so for me I like the idea that
the brother it was it was somebody that
he never thought he could get it it
ended and he never really knew why it
ended and they're at a charitable
charity function he's gotten the funky
brother to go with him right and and
right away there's a story for the pilot
that's a great pilot story but I think
you always have to say to yourself and
easier said than done is this could like
Crale Rosenthal said could this happen
is it plausible and filius to do I don't
know if you've been watching the history
of comedy on CNN but it's wonderful and
one of the things they you know it
wasn't in our book unfortunately fills
in her book but he said that he is his
assignment every weekend was go home and
get in a fight
with your spouse and come back on Monday
and tell me about it oh great
so I think that's having to I think
that's kind of adding to to what Peters
saying is find something not that's
never been done because everything has
been done and what's gonna make it
unique is your voice now the other thing
about your premise that we have to make
sure of is it's not that tough to write
a pilot episode but how are we going to
get two years worth of stories feeling
the intima so I mean when we present
when you're trying to sell it we can't
go in there with three ideas we have to
start showing where this can go
remembering that in a sitcom each
episode is got a little arc lit but a
can of a beginning a middle and an end
because the characters have to endure
from week to week they're gonna want to
see the carrot juice drink or drinking
carrot juice every week so he can't
change that and the other guy has to be
kind of a sleaze ball druggie guy even
though he can go in and out of detox all
the time he can have new resolves to
stop each time you know he could drink
carrot juice with his brother then go
back and get his bourbon to drink later
when he's not looking
but those characters have to endure so
that every time something happens we can
see the two of them react to it
differently let me give you an example
of a really successful show that started
in 2005 and went off in 2014 so nine
seasons many Emmys I met your mother
the two guys that created it were they
new at the very beginning of the show
they knew how the last episode would end
if you watch the nine seasons you see
how they go to that story people change
over the nine years and and because you
also have to be aware and this is
another thing I tell students because
they forget the difference between
writing a novel or writing a short story
is when you're writing anything dramatic
you're not you're primarily writing it a
to get a producer interested or you know
not in television it's not directors but
you're also writing it for actors to
speak and if an actor isn't interested
it's not gonna get made no matter how
good it is so I think people a lot of
times forget how important good dialogue
is and the only way that you can really
in the end write sitcom is if you can
write dialogue I think that you could
probably get away with writing a good
action movie if your dialogue is okay
because they're gonna hire poor Carrie
Fisher used to get hired to rewrite
dialogue at three hundred thousand a
week and Charlie Peters used to do that
work and but but you know you just take
the movie about the tornado about 20
year with Helen Hunt and yeah and poor
Bill Paxton and and and you know they
had lines alike hold on to your seat I
mean you really don't have to write you
know don't let that table go you don't
think I'm stealing from Rob Reiner I
think he was making jokes about a play
you know you can write those kind of
movies and be okay
there's no way that you can write a
great I mean the thing the best thing
about Fraser was the dialogue and how
each character nobody spoke like anybody
else it was and again it all came out of
character character traits that the
dialogue has to match the traits yeah
okay good point so let's say with our
two brothers so we have Adam who's he
chooses his words very carefully he
wants to make sure that he doesn't
offend anybody
he's totally there was a there was an
old Thomas maan book called transposed
heads where they had a holy man who
would walk through the woods with a
broom sweeping in front of him so he
didn't step on any insects he was a
taoist okay so again he's going to be a
character that is so PC that it's gonna
be scary right and he wants to make sure
nobody is ever offended I have an idea
okay please Peters gave me an idea I
think he should have a charity that he I
think you should ever found
that means he has work now that me
personally I'm just I personally I don't
know which is correct I'm tired of
seeing shows where people don't work or
we don't know anything about what they
do and I'm also tired of seeing shows
where it's all about the work so I'm
kind of a curmudgeon about this but what
if we had a foundation okay it's a it's
a 501c3 yeah it's gone through and he's
got the money and he's given up the
corporate life for this which goes along
with what you pitched and he wants his
brother to work right he wants his
brother to have the sense of the work
ethic that he has and he and he can
stand what the idea Peter gave me is he
picks a charity and I couldn't come up
with that right now but he picks a
charity but I said something that nobody
else would pick that is a little bit
wacky because that you get stories out
of but the you know the Daoist thing of
brushing the you know brushing the
insects out of the way is funny I'm not
saying do that but I would try to find
something that not a lot of other people
who start foundations would do you know
in foundations you get a lot of power to
choose who you're gonna give money to I
mean the Ford Foundation is famous for
that that they have overlooked some
really good people and given money all
foundations okay but I could also see
that if you go to his office at the
foundation everything looks pretty cool
but if you know him a little better and
you go back you can't believe he's
living in a tiny little hovel apartment
well Warren Buffett so yeah he lives in
a little town in Nebraska yeah so the
whole idea of you could afford to have
your own Trump Tower if you wanted ooh
yeah everything was going so great
erasing wait wait wait what I'm making a
contrast from him sheesh see you can be
too PC I think it's called being peed on
here no but the very idea that people
think they see him in this large scale
you know incredible place for his
charity because he's doing everything
scale to make the charity work not
realizing that in his own personal life
he comes back and you know he's wearing
sweat pants and he's you know sitting on
the floor doing yoga and he's got to
push the furniture aside because there's
not enough furniture to do all the
postures in the room and that's the way
he wants this austere lifestyle and then
his brother could constantly be like if
he goes to work for him saying look you
look at this palace were working in why
are we living in this hovel so this
constantly pressure saying loosen up
loosen up the purse strings you don't
have you wear new buy new sweatpants
right right he feels guilty so with the
dialog between the two of them how would
it be because although they they have
two different mindsets and styles of
relating to people but they've also
known each other since they were very
young first thing it makes me think of
is Adam is hyper PC but he's human so
every once in a while when he bangs his
chin on the tub something else is gonna
come out when something makes him really
angry something is gonna come out that
all of a sudden like ooh instead of this
my middle finger just came out oh I just
spoke Italian yeah so each one of those
little bursts these lapses become very
funny because it's out of character or
it's what he doesn't want him you know
he doesn't want to let that out of
himself he thinks he's purged himself of
all of that sure so it becomes much
funnier when he does it and and how on
the nose is the dialogue because they
kind of know each other with you well I
mean it seems like you know when they
say when when two people know each other
for a long time they almost don't even
have to say the full sentence they can
just say a word they can grunt and the
other person knows what that means yes
to me what I got but tell me what's
funny is that Evan remains consistent
all the way through but Adam went
through his transformation so he doesn't
talk like he used to and that that
really pisses Evan off saying you know
what happened the guy that I still you
know playing you know play catch with in
the back you know
where is he gone now everything you're
saying is no let your you know somebody
tried to prick the bubble all the time
Sims and sometimes it makes him
frustrated sometimes he takes it as a
challenge I mean I remember as a kid I I
had a job working swing shift at a
credit card company in the mailroom and
one of the guys there was a Mormon and
he would bring Herman he was bringing
his lunch every day and he wouldn't hang
out with anybody else and people would
constantly try and get him angry and
like they would take a paper clip in a
rubberband go up behind him and smack
him in the head that really hurts and
instead of getting mad and say please
don't do that that really hurts and then
all of a sudden you'd feel guilty for
doing it but you do something else
because you wanted him to curse at you
and the more he wouldn't curse the more
mean that things were that you tried to
do to get him to break so I could see
Evan constantly prodding saying how can
i how can I get him to break this facade
that I know was really a facade all
right so I just thought of something
else again he gave me particularly on
the networks but I think everywhere now
there has to be something going on well
I take Fraser for example if it had just
been the father living with Fraser and
the brothers problems I don't think the
show would have worked they needed him
to be a radio psychiatrist that was a
big part of the show you had to have
somewhere to go where you got him
because the premise of that show was
Fraser hangs him severy we could you
know hang some falls on his own what's
that expression know your own petard
yeah and he you know he would give
someone fault you know but the thing
that I think this show needs which it
doesn't quite have yet although you're
on the way we've been working on it
twelve minutes that's nothing right is
you need some kind of platform there's a
networks you know in other words this be
more at stake than just their relation
so so for example god no I was gonna say
we had the model before they the two of
them competing again for the same woman
who could be living next door just as
easily even I wouldn't buy that show no
no well not enough at stake for me I
mean I've seen that it's a romantic
comedy I wouldn't want to watch that
every week a big bang did okay with that
what big bang did okay with a pretty
good bang has the other of their
scientists and the one no I'm just
saying the fact that normally here are
two guys who don't compete one is
successful one is his on his knees
begging all the time right so to wear
what arena can they possibly compete in
there's sort of only one well the model
though she might tempt the carrot juice
meditating brother back into his old
ways but the whole point is that would
be in but but the whole point is he's
constantly monitoring himself from going
back there and I remember I had an
argument with an old friend of mine wait
who a second hold it you had an argument
with someone who was a fundamentalist
Baptist minister and we talked about the
movie The Last Temptation of Christ they
and I was saying Christ wins he battles
his own temptation and triumphs over it
so as a psychologist I'm saying he
talked himself out of doing something
that was bad trying for the spirit and
he said no we believe once you entertain
the thought you're guilty of Commission
of the sin and so again this whole idea
that he's constantly battling him I've
got to keep myself pure and so she could
you know she wants to you know hey you
know if you're gonna be with me you
gotta loosen up and take a little drink
you got to take a hit on this joint you
got a you know all the things you don't
think that's a show yet though I mean
those are all really good ideas but know
about comedy as opposed to drama comedy
is much harder to write there's no
question about that because I think
people could agree
pretty much on what drama is and isn't
everybody's got an opinion about comedy
but for me anyway one of the reasons I
think Grayson Frankie works if you
haven't seen it do you know what the
premises
I don't okay so it's two older women in
their 70s who don't like each other
dream funny Jane Fonda is the sort of
she was a model and then started a very
famous business there their husband or
law partners and Lily Tomlin who in real
life is one of Jane Fonda's closest
friends is a sort of hippie dippie
bright woman who's still in the early
70s and their husbands they all go to
dinner and the women think they're going
to announce that they're retiring and
instead they announce that they're in
love they're gay and they want to move
in together and so you have that it
isn't just the two women who are so
different have to live together because
what happens is the women get the beach
house in Malibu and the men take one of
the two houses in town and I could you
know I haven't watched it since the
first season but it's really good and
what I think this is just my opinion but
what I think makes it work is you've got
both things going and you've got more
stories because you've also got Martin
Sheen and Sam Waterston story you've got
that children populated this sitcom but
it isn't just populating it I think what
a network is gonna say if you're going
to a network there's a lot of shows on
Netflix that are very thin and still
really you know there's one show called
love which is just about a these two
mismatched people who date each other
and fall in love and they they would
never be together and I lost interest in
the show after a while because that's
all it was and that's just me but for me
if I'm going to a network with this I
would have to have a you you have to
have somewhere that this thing takes
place other than the apartment because
I'm gonna get bored and I don't know how
I'm gonna get four seasons no that's
what everyone remember ok so as always I
agree with Jeffrey
and and think for open universe for
openers you know two easy ways to go or
one they're in their 40s their parents
could still be around and so you can
have a whole new set of conflicts in
there plus they're at work and since
he's got him there at work
you've got a whole bunch of different
people in there to interact with and
again you can have people at this place
of work that range anywhere from you
know they'd rather die than see a
dolphin in a tuna tuna net to people who
were saying hey let's put on some rock
shows let's really get some glitz here
let's get more celebs involved here so I
mean there's all kinds of place that's
good but yeah but I'm saying but
initially I still want to get what are
the big conflicts between the two main
characters because they you want to make
sure they're seeing everything
differently and that their goals are
always crossed now interestingly one of
our favorite interviews in in whatever
one about twenty four you mean one of
our favorite one of our 24 favorite
interviews and now that's funny was when
we did Leonard Stern again who made a
big point of saying conflict as it is it
the absolute base of all my comedy but
it's never hostile it's always out of
love and we talked about it it's kind of
like it took me back when I heard that I
Love Lucy where every episode of I Love
Lucy was you know they all love their
their best friends and each other but
they always had a conflict about what
they should be doing to express that
love you know we should go here no we
should go there we should buy this no we
shouldn't buy this and it was always
this would be best for you listen to me
I know better but always banging heads
but not trying to hurt the other person
not competing but saying because I love
you I want what's best for you okay and
so again one of the interesting things
in this comedy that I've seen the
premise that makes it good is they are
brothers so no matter how bitterly they
fight bottom line they're going to take
care of each other
maybe the father was successful and had
a bankruptcy and they had to downsize so
they always remembered that experience
of being on like the good neighborhood
and then for a temporary setback the dad
had to move them to maybe a rougher part
of town and to go to public school then
you lose me I'm just gonna play Network
because I'll always disagree with
anything okay and that's not silly bad
that means that there's like Oh Pedro
says that means they're engaged
it doesn't mean you made a sale but at
least you got them involved then as a
network executive I would say yeah but
then you lose the foundation whereas if
the father had made a very big success
of the foundation I've never seen a show
about a foundation by the way about a
about a you know a non-profit that's
like the Ford Foundation of the Carnegie
5fc Matt actually there was a bunch of
episodes about one in Modern Family
yeah but that wasn't the series right no
but he worked at it for like a real
estate guy who are we talking about no
one of the the redheaded gay brother
Oh worked at a phase a lawyer right and
so he worked but but anyway um you know
whatever do that and a meeting by the
way let them do that
what but they just did Oh what do you
I'm sorry we'll never tell them when
you're pitching to them what others
should that's kind of passe it used to
be it used to be when you were pitching
something you would say it's
such-and-such meet such-and-such
people hate that now because they want
you to come in especially in TV I don't
know about movies but anyway go ahead
down I mean he's taking the rest of the
interview I'm not saying another word
yeah that'll be sorry let me just
interject and I don't know if I should
be doing I like in the pigeon room but
but my point was that they bonded over
having sort of a fall from grace there's
no need to go yeah and so they even
though they're at polar they're you know
they're they're lifestyles are different
their ethics are different they remember
those hard times cuz they got bullied in
school
Geoffrey
three and I gave a couple of talks at a
a organization called script fest and he
bought me a t-shirt that said what if
the big letters so you're doing a
what-if which is great at the inner
writers room
what we'd all be doing then is saying
okay what if it was the mom that made
the big success and dad always felt
weird about and what happens if they him
so there's so many different places to
take it and I remember when when Mark
and Paul did their interview that would
big March at lunch at all no mark Paul
shit lick and Mark Shepler right yeah
and they started out with they were
doing talking about square dancing in
Arizona and they got it to how JEWS
don't square dance he so yes they do
it's a great place to meet women and
everybody go have sex after a square
dance and often they ended up with a an
outlaw harley-davidson shop with a
motorcycle gang so just just from
playing like we're playing here this was
so good but it's just the idea of you
know you kick around ideas do you see
where it goes but again for me I keep
taking it back to the two guys have to
be as opposite as we could make them and
there always has to be pressure so the
fact that he's got money and doesn't
want to use it this way and he wants the
money is a great source of pressure and
then all the different ways he tries to
get it so sometimes he looks like he's
reformed thinking he'll get it that way
and no and sometimes he sees the con and
doesn't get it so you always have that
constant pressure but underlying it
still you have the bond that their
brothers will always help each other you
know so there's caring at the same time
this really strident competition you
have a good basis and then any situation
you put them in they're always going to
see it differently Bob or C who is a big
producer writer a lot of features luck
created a lot of drama series works a
lot with JJ Abrams he told me that
post-2008 every television show series
that will be on will be so influenced by
and he turned out to be right that by
cable and and now Netflix that there
will be even sitcoms will there won't
there'll be very few shows where the
characters don't grow in the old days
when I started on sitcoms you could
watch a show and then not watch 10 shows
and you can come right back to it that's
going away I think and I think that's a
great thing because it means the
characters can go reap is the perfect
example of that yes it's a sitcom but
and she's horrible she's I don't know if
you've ever seen it but she's Julia
louis-dreyfus louis-dreyfus his
character is just an awful human being
but she's doing it with this wink and a
nod and it's satire so you like her and
but she changes a lot and the situation
changes but what makes that show work is
that she's the bite when you meet her
she's about to be the Vice President Lee
the first woman vice president and so I
was raised and this is just you know how
I was brought into the businesses what
do you call see I'm losing words today I
couldn't take a marshmallow what is it
you know when you actually buy it you
better cut this later but the when you
buy a Best Western there really is no
Best Western chain you buy it and you
get to use their towels in their name
and all what's that : choice franchise
network still to this day talk about a
franchise and that they want to know and
it's a way of helping them get story so
my vote is that the straight brother was
changed by having to take over the
foundation and he brings the other
brother in to help him and then because
he's helping him all hell breaks loose I
mean that would be one way to go it's
certainly not the only way to go
other way is to have them on their
uppers which is what you suggested I you
know that they're broke
either way can work you know what it
really all depends on Karen is the
writer and he could because the greatest
premise in the world can be ruined by
lousy writing so and again it all goes
back to as an actor want to play this
because we're past the day when you
could get something on even Aaron Sorkin
can't get something on if a good actor
doesn't want to play it and he's a
playwright so he comes from theater he
wouldn't want to do something without
really great actors
that's why Woody Allen Oh a says two
actors hey if you don't like the words
change the words you're the actor you're
the one with the ear not many writers
will say that so might might note to any
writer out there who's just starting you
need you need to know that you are
writing for actors you are not writing
just for executives you have to write
dial and that's why I get people to read
it have a reading refine your dialogue
because people read five pages and if
they're not taken they're not gonna read
the rest so I'm saying that one of the
showrunner told me recently who works
for us actually it's Bob Meyer told me
that what you want in a room is the
twelve to four Deana takes about four
days to get a story that's why they
weren't work on multiple stories at a
time because they're on a deadline
you know the writers come back on a
network show the actors leave in June or
late May or maybe even April and then
everybody takes a hiatus and they and
the writers come back in late May early
June and they've got to get they've got
to get a head start on twenty four shows
so they can't be working on one story at
a time but they break the stories in the
room and this is the first step of that
and then that the decider is the
showrunner ago you know I've seen it
happen I've been in rooms where it's
happened where
go well you may like foundations and you
may like the brothers being rich but
nobody that's not my show and I want it
this way so there's usually a pilot that
has been written by one person not by a
staff so that the tone has been set you
know and if you have a great showrunner
like Phil Rosenthal or Bob they want a
lot of involvement but bob says it's
disagreement is wonderful arguing and
being like my idea is better than your
idea and screw you and screw you that's
not a good room to be in that's a nasty
room and does that open but I was in a
room briefly where people topped each
other and it was not a pleasant
experience I tell the story about Walt
Bennett that's a great example it's
gonna tell a different story but I'll
tell that one first I take only one cell
two stories I take requests no wonder
Bert when Walt was a it was a was a baby
writer in a room he he pitched a joke
and oil painting and then 20 minutes
later a more seasoned writer told the
same people to same joke everybody
cracked up and so Walt said hey I just
pitched that joke 20 minutes ago and
they said come on don't be like that
that is an excellent example of what I
was saying but one of the writers was
David Beckmann was telling us what it's
like to write on SNL and he said the the
competition is so fierce because you've
got a 90-minute show you've got two
musical episodes you've got Weekend
Update
you've got the intro where they the guy
comes in and then half of the cast at
least has standing characters that they
write for so there's only a few new bits
every week and all the writers in the
room were competing to try and get
something in those couple of little
spots so it's really fierce and if you
go long enough without getting your
stuff on the
what are we paying you for and you're
gone yeah it was tough I've been told
that he's tough but he's right he's
right yeah but you can imagine the
pressure of a new writer coming in there
and it's it's a battle you know you have
to have it's like walking the streets of
New York you got elbows you know if
you're gonna get anywhere plus no one
tells you the unspoken rules and the
things because you know then you're a
threat yeah maybe you'll your story like
this foundation story will you know
supersede anything else it's but you
know there's a thing that but there's an
interesting thing that happened and here
an interesting dynamic that we'll
mention for a minute which is we you you
asked us how we would establish a story
and and then in the middle of it you
said well how about if we did this to it
and one of the ways you tell seasoned
writers from new writers a lot of
writers unfortunately when they're
pitching a story let me intrude with a
joke how many producers does it take to
screw in a light bulb
the answer is does it have to be a light
bulb it's that terrible old Hollywood
Joe but it gets to the idea that when
you're pitching a story sometimes the
producer or the exec who's listening
will start saying well could it be this
couldn't we do this couldn't we do that
and they start to think hey whose story
is this and I'm the writer and what do
you foolish that that's as the French
say an amateur when you're a seasoned
writer and the person you're pitching to
makes any suggestion at all you say
that's wonderful give me more because
you're starting to get a creative
collaboration going they're interested
enough and what you're saying to want to
be part of it and you want to invite
that that's the beginning of a green
light yeah and part of the irony is half
the time they don't even remember what
they said you don't have to use it but
it doesn't matter the minute the minute
they are invested enough to want to make
suggestions they're saying I've got
something that's hitting them yeah I
tell you Bob horsey again
me that we were well we he came just
became to to LMU and he gave a talk and
then he followed it up by bringing a JJ
Abrams and a bunch of other people but
some one of the grad students got up and
said well you know you've done a lot of
movies you know he did all the
spider-man movies you know start for all
these things and he's and this kid said
well what if you don't like the doubt
and he said what do you mean if I don't
like the net walk do you have to take
the nose he said I have to make sense of
the note under the note so that I can
make the executive happy because that's
my boss you know if you were you you
know everybody has to take those believe
me
Spielberg still pigs now it's probably
fewer than we do but you know when we
were working on this book Rudy gave us
some notes I don't I don't think that I
know for a fact Peter wasn't happy with
all of them but what Peter could do
really really well is he can he can
translate the note so that he could make
the editor/publisher happy but still
kind and that's what Bob was saying is
you have you can't turn your back on
people who are paying you and that
that's sort of a that's a young person's
fantasy I don't think there's any part
of the arts where you could do that a
poet can't do that and a nice part to
talk about here is that when you're
pitching a project people think okay did
you like my work and in many many cases
they don't buy the work you brought in
it but they might say but I like the way
you work I like the way you think and
they'll say we have this other project
would you be interested so you're in
there pitching yourself sometimes more
than your project and so if you go in
there saying what do you mean it they
have to be 30 years old I had him in
there as 24 year olds you're done then
coach just said why would we ever want
to work with you yeah there is what if
you're saying hmm
30 well
that I like that you know you have a
much better chance of I say this art
Peter this morning that I believe that
we're in a period of less tolerance for
entitlement than ever before that that
JJ Abrams has a rule he and his wife
with their company that the minute
someone shows any form of entitlement
any form of you know where's my office
with the corner view on the 12th floor
buy because there's just too many people
who won't behave that way and and you
know it used to be now I'm sure there
are still people who can get away with
that
you know but I think unless you looked
at me when he said that I didn't look at
you I was afraid to look at you anyway
right if I were to go in to pitch this
to someone and I was pitching it to the
two of you and you you both said and we
yeah we don't like this in this in this
so would the open and workable response
from me ie the writer be great I can
come back and change it and could we
meet again with friends I think you have
to do oh I'm sorry I mean I I would not
say that I would say what parts of it
didn't you like how would you like to
see it done because if they haven't
started the creative collaboration maybe
I can start it and so if they said well
I see it you know working much better
with a you know for a younger market and
I'd like to make these you know
mid-teens let's say oh wow I hadn't
thought of it that way yeah then you
could dad it out it out or not and the
more I the more I can get you involved
it's another trick that we learned from
someone who's not in the book my mentor
who is in his 90s now but sharpest
attack and he he used to go in and pitch
tell them you know like ongoing series
and let's say but you oh by the way
you're never gonna go to a pilot meeting
and have one pilot idea and you're going
to have somebody who's
or powerful than you or you're not gonna
get anywhere and you're gonna have an
agent who got you in the door unless
you're very lucky and I'm not sure
that's luck because you do need someone
looking out for you and protecting you
but the other thing the Peters always
said and this I think comes from a
science background is try to find out
what kinds of things that producer that
executive likes because if you go in and
pitch them westerns and they hate
westerns you're dead before you open
your mouth and that's maybe more for
movies I don't know but let me say but
just to follow that idea if you have an
idea for Western and you know that
they've made a movie about an orphan and
that really touched their heart then you
make sure you have an orphan in your
Western so that you have a way to
connect or if you're like me you try to
find out what directors they admire it
and then find a Western that director
raised so for example you know they like
Martin Ritt and they think Martin grid
is the greatest direct flying that to
find some way in I guess is what we're
saying and the other the other thing is
when they say no move on
don't argue never get defensive never
argue yeah because you never want to go
in with one idea you're going what I do
you're asking unless you know obviously
Aaron Sorkin they're gonna come there I
mean there's a group of people they go
to pilot writing is almost in my
experience and I think it's the same as
it is now
he's almost never done by beginners they
want to go and it makes sense for them
right so if for example you pitch this
to a showrunner the only way you're
gonna get it made because you don't have
any I'm not talking about you in reality
I'm talking about you this person who
hypothetically puts this well you're
gonna want somebody who really knows
what they're doing or they won't bury
you and they'll make a bad deal with you
whoever you want someone who's got some
chops and some power
okay can we slip in a little bit of
pedantry for just a moment please
my favorite I don't know what it means
comes from academia one of like one of
my one of my favorite books is a book
called Thinking Fast and Slow it's
probably the smartest book I've read in
the last 30 years and it it basically
has the thesis that we have two modes of
thinking one where we get very very
rigorous and think very hard and deep
and the other is we think intuitively
and we make just about all our decisions
intuitively and what's kind of
interesting is that when we're forced to
think deeply which we don't like to do
because it's hard not only are we
thinking deeply but we're cranky as
we're doing it because it takes a lot of
our resources and we're kind of
skeptical as we're doing it because
we're forced to think hard it's not in
our regular way of looking at things so
when I'm pitching something I'm thinking
how can I keep this so that they're
intuitively accepting everything I do I
don't want to put them in a place where
they have to go contrary so if I made
some controversial statement like you
know I've got this idea for a horror
film because we know that everybody
secretly always wants to do terrible
things to the people around them and
somebody says wait a minute I don't want
to do terrible things to people around
me the minute I've got them at that
point
I've lost them and I have to now find
instances and then they're going to
negate them and we're arguing instead of
finding something they're gonna agree
with right away and say you know most of
us like you know the easy way out when
things are really pleasant and so we
make decisions like yeah I do that yeah
yeah and then they're cruising along
with me and I've got a better chance the
minute I make them skeptical I've got a
really tough mountain to climb that the
fellow who wrote this book Daniel
Kahneman is a Princeton psychologist
psychology professor who won the Nobel
Prize for economics it's a brilliant
book and I get no royalties from it
which hurts me no it's already but I
praise it anyway
think I took grace low it's a great book
but it just makes that really good point
that anything that you're saying to
somebody that seems like it's within
their realm of possibility that they can
accept without arguing you've got an
easier sell than if you're stopping and
saying well imagine this I can't see
that ever happening I just want to come
back to something you said you said
they'll bury you if you don't can you
what I mean is that that what what a lot
of people don't want to see I can't say
all people who are experienced is an
inexperienced person actually a young
person in their early 20s coming in and
doing something that's above their skill
level they know what you don't know
because they've been doing it even
junior executives who have a very short
life span know that and you always want
to dial up you always want to bring
somebody with you who knows more than
you do and can believe in you and help
you those are also great partnerships a
20 I'll give you an example I also
talked told Peter this story this
morning I had a student two years ago I
always I also told him that I'm gonna
look like the hero of this I'm really
not this is just my job I used to hear
oh no his divers like somebody somebody
has to make me the hero somewhere I'm
the villain everywhere else you can say
how are you sorry busy today I think
that the the best example is I have a
student two years ago who was the best
joke writer I 21 years old and had done
a lot of improv but very young and she
could work on which is just what you
want in a room she could work on other
people's scripts and go you know this
would be a great joke and they would all
come from character and conflict and she
said to me in the beginning of the year
because it was a two semester course she
said to me I'm gonna come out of here at
22 and I'm going right on to a
television series
as a writer and I said to her I hope not
and and she got really mad at me and I
said hey you won't be ready be they'll
eat you alive and see they'll resent you
and so what you need to do is pay your
dues and then I found this or she found
this program
daddy second city in Chicago had started
a grad program in Harold Ramis named in
his memory and she applied and she got
in and she just graduated in May I think
or she has maybe six months to go she's
got one more semester and she is like a
different kid because she took her time
you don't want to put your so I guess to
go back to your question is you don't
want to put yourself in a position where
you will get killed because they will
kill you they have so many people to see
and they're looking for things that they
can sell it's still a business no matter
what it's on you know even PBS oh you
know British television people yes it's
so high-quality it is but it's it's
government supported on the BBC so you
know we'll see things like the crown and
things like that you know or Downton
Abbey that we can't you know we have we
rarely see here except now we're seeing
it on Netflix so I just think it's
always a good idea to dial up don't try
to be when you're young don't go in and
pretend to know that get people to
mentor you I think is the best advice
I've ever been given and it's the best
advice I could give is and take your
time because you want to be in it for
the long haul you don't want to have
like a gold strike and be done by the
time you're 25 this girl if she done
what she was had in her head she would
have been finished in 25 I think you
know how many how many if you look at
Orson Welles career his later career
even though he made some great movies he
didn't have the career he had at 26 it's
too young but he was a genius so that
doesn't really count but I think there's
a lot of social pressure and I know for
Generation Xers like myself that existed
but now I see it firmly Niels and Gen Z
this not even
just like the 30 under 30 group of
people that I mean but think about then
there's now probably 25 but we see
younger and younger people what I tell
my students is great things get into the
business in any job you can get into pay
your dues and don't say oh within the
year I've got to be in a writers room as
an assistant because knowledge answers
and if the lucky chance that it happens
great for you and then bring your
friends along because really when we
tell particularly grad students on the
first day of grad schools look right and
look left because that's not just your
posse those are the people who are gonna
hire you later you know but LMU is not
like other film schools it's it's not
competitive it's more collaborative so I
you know I know USC is very competitive
and I think that's too bad because
collaborative environment is always
better to nurture other people while
you're trying to get what you want means
that you'll always have people you're
working with most of my seniors come out
and they're if they haven't changed
their mind about writing they work
they're all listed this crop of seniors
that just graduated in May they're all
working in the business but will want to
edit the bad stuff about USC out of
there ya know well we see grad we can't
ask this though no schools mentioned but
how can one tell a collaborative
environment versus competitive because
sometimes competitive can mask as
collaborative and then once you've been
around a little bit you start to see no
don't care well about not just their own
work but other people's work are they
involved do they work on other peels
work I think that I think that's a big
tell and one of the teachers like one of
the what what what are you boss is like
now the difference between school and a
job is hey if your boss is an asshole
there's not much you could do about that
except quit so you're gonna and it's
good for you to work for assholes I
think because you learn
especially early on because you will
learn how to deal with difficult people
oh yeah heart alike right
so unfortunately look I have to work
with Peter every day I mean yeah but you
you've asked a really nuanced question
good-o nuanced because I don't you're
making it sound like it's binary
are you collab we don't know the word
binary Peter zero zero one one no
because she's thinking mathematic he
means it's not one of the other okay
I'll give my answer in I okay right I
doubt it
I'm patient just like Adam you start
speaking if you start speaking English
perhaps and so the fact is in any
environment the the difference the
places where you find that it's
competitive you'll find people being
very evaluative particularly negatively
availa if that's not a good idea because
that wouldn't work the cause and a love
that of my but but good ideas are always
recognized so it's always competitive
because if you have the best ideas
you're recognized as the best like LMU
is is works really hard to be a
supportive environment yet jeffrey said
here is the student who clearly was head
and shoulder above everybody else you're
going to get noticed by the quality of
your ideas so it's competitive to the
extent that you could you could stratify
who are the best of the worst writers
whether you're come you know whether
you're supportive or competitive but the
difference is the the lumps you take
along the way yeah in other words some
people again come with this idea of look
it's an aggressive marketplace we want
to prepare you for it so if your ideas
suck we're gonna let you know it because
then you won't have so many sucky ideas
later yeah as opposed to other places I
mean I know for example people come to
me all the time with ideas saying you
know can you give me notes here's my
script years and what I found is hard
for that I think what I find is I almost
never give criticisms what I do is I ask
and so if something doesn't work for me
I don't say that doesn't work or that's
no good I say have you thought about
this
or why is it work to have this be that
is there another way to do that so it's
never coming out as a put-down because
people get very defensive when you put
their stuff down and I don't want them
either and I don't want to dampen their
you know their enthusiasm and at the
same point I don't think it's helpful
we're asking them thought-provoking
questions that they can answer
eventually if they're smart enough they
realize it's a criticism or it's a flaw
but it's not negative it makes them
think how do I solve a problem so I'd
like to recast that it's problem-solving
you know I think it helps to realize
that believe it or not Aaron Sorkin has
written some pretty crummy scripts and
he would probably be the first to say so
so you know even the best people are not
at there but there's a famous mom W
Somerset mom saying that only mediocre
writers are their best all the time so
you know I think I think that what I try
to do in class and you know probably
some of this is influenced by Peter that
it really hurts that the complement of
music you can see the pain in his face
is 90 meek it will never occur to me to
say to any student and I haven't I
haven't had the experience of a student
with zero Talent I've never had that
because it's really hard to get into LM
you know and we are number eight out of
ten we're in the top ten film schools
now so I plug for LMU but even someone
who was really untalented I would
probably do what Peter just said I would
probably say do you really want to write
but I would never say you have no talent
for writing because a lot of people said
that to me they didn't say it knows
words but a lot of people discouraged me
and I think discouraging someone is
really awful it's an awful thing to do
you never know what someone will do
later but if you let me have a little
hold on hold on hold on
I almost got a word a stay I wasn't
finished my speech I was gonna say
something nice about you if you had told
me ten years ago when I met Peter that
he was gonna write a novel I would have
said now Peter will never write a novel
that's something Gator doesn't do he's
not only written the novel he's really
working hard on it now you can interrupt
me but notice he didn't say it's really
good
he said he's really working it's getting
there manual or no that historical novel
which by the way is the hardest genre
there is oh right about yeah just you
know even when your ass got questions I
think you have to be really careful
because questions can be very evaluative
sure um you know why did you decide to
wear that dress today it's hot the point
is that's that's a question we have
those questions that's an evaluation
source what I'm so so even asking
questions even asking questions like you
know why do you want to be writing you
have to be very careful because that
could be a very discouraging question
right well I've Auvergne an evaluative
question that I would like to ask and
that would be do you think at a writer
that has talent but no connections has
an easier time getting in the business
versus a writer that has not as much
talent but connections that's a that's a
trick question because it's not because
it really depends on and depends on the
circle the ratios of both yeah that's
the scientific but but i but I have to
tell you contacts oh it's really big you
know they're an awful lot of people who
will never never never get noticed no
matter how good they are cuz that's the
work will just never get out of that box
true and knowing people the big
advantage
but you know we were talking about this
before today that you know the the
importance of the N word in Hollywood
that
networking is more important than
anything it's the more people you can
work with the more people you can
collaborate with it's just when when
there's a position open in a room you're
a lot more likely to call friends you
know then just say hey we got an open
spot here come in an audition so more
work gets given to people who know
people than any other way I like what
you said about the evaluative questions
though because I think we've all had
that happen to us in one form or another
where somebody's asking a question yeah
and then they're like I'm just asking a
question but it's the intention fine I
had a clinical supervisor who would
really get down on me saying don't make
a statement through a question I'm most
afraid to know it's just if I said use
the same question again you know why did
you choose to wear that dress today
right that's like saying you know that's
not really an appropriate dress though I
can tell the intention yeah and so again
it's like you have to be careful with
even when you're saying why does your
character you know why did he choose to
be a cowboy you know it's like I'm
saying that you shouldn't have had him
be a cowboy yeah I can see you were
possibly paying for it I think that
changes there but I mean I think I think
the important thing is when you're
asking questions to give them the
appearance of wanting information rather
than giving it evaluations right and
surprisingly people don't really like
being evaluated negatively that much
yeah they just summarize how much
practice do TV writers use structure
when writing out episodes and a season
okay I think I answered this earlier
when I was talking about how rooms work
and this is really comes up in the book
a lot I have yet this is happening more
and more on drop dramas shows by the way
never had rooms up until not
long ago the drama room is based on the
comedy room and the comedy room is based
on the Sid Caesar show show of shows
from nineteen fifty six or seven sixteen
seventy years old whatever someone
didn't like my headline for that ad I've
never forgotten that
he's very valuable with me by the way
but I'm straight up with it you straight
up with it which doesn't make it hurt
any less when you spend and we're back
to Italian hand gestures so so the sorry
could you ask the question oh sure
do TV writers use structure when writing
out episodes and the season episodes
don't work the same way as pilots so
let's say you're on the second year of
Modern Family or the sixth year of
Modern Family the staffs already had
change overs people have left gotten
their own deals their own show first
thing you're gonna get is a Bible and
the Bible the show Bible is every show
every episode that's ever been done
since the show started
then they're gonna then you're gonna sit
in a room for 12 hours a day minimum and
you're gonna break story you're gonna
pitch and break stories then someone
then from the from the break the break
is really an outline then someone is
gonna go out probably an assistant and
or and and type up the outline from the
break and they're gonna come back in
they're gonna they're gonna go over the
outline then somebody is gonna go out do
a pass a draft come back in they'll
table that rewrite it as a group so on
television episodic TV yes the
showrunners design the arc of the show
and have the say on what's going to
happen but there's a lot of work that
goes on in the room that has absolutely
you know it's it's lots of things going
on at once but it's a particularly good
question because it's of all they suck
up you be I shouldn't make obscene
gestures I know but can you see me if I
hit him in the back of the head
but because it's evolving right now and
again it used to be every character has
to remain the same even though that that
episode is changing so again as Jeffrey
said before you can miss 10 episodes and
you can still follow along with the
sitcom where now it's becoming more
episodic and you kind of have to keep up
or all of a sudden how did we get here
all this has changed so what you're
asking is good only because it's
evolving so much and I'm seeing a shift
right but the parted question about
structure is it I you know there might
be shows in doing a different way but
but but I can't see it not coming out of
character in conflict first so I know
for example the most famous story I
don't think it made it into the book but
but but Phil Rosenthal story about how
they got the you know how did he get the
idea for the pilot which is that he gave
his parents in real life fruit of the
Month Club and his mother had a raging
like what what we're we're too
you think we're too old to go out and
get our own fruit you know and he used
that as the part of the pilot episode
that he gave and he gave that to Doris
Roberts and Peter Boyle as their problem
with Ray and and so he had the story
idea and you could see immediate
conflict and the great thing about
Raymond was that the stories were always
small with big stakes so that was
another famous episode was somebody in
the room said I I'm having a fight with
my wife because we came back from
vacation and the suitcase is on the
landing and all the men in the room said
don't touch it make her go upstairs you
know and the women in the room said the
suitcase for her now that seems like a
really tiny story but it's it's really
about marriage right so they start with
that and then they start because they
know the show they know the characters
they know what they do what they
wouldn't do which you don't know and
pilot and and so they can say well ray
when you know Debra would never say that
because basically she loves right but
she thinks he's a dope but also what
Geoffrey's saying goes back to when we
were developing your pilot about this
notion of plausibility and add to it the
notion of identification that people
want to see stuff that feels real to
them that even though I might never have
been put in this situation I know how I
would act if I was in that situation
yeah exactly
I'll tell you what I think is almost an
interesting story um I had a friend who
got stuck on a screenplay and we we sat
down in this very room and I took a
psych history of his character and by
the time he left he said wow it's like
whatever happens to my character now I
know exactly how he'll respond and he
said the rest of the screenplay was just
so easy because he knew his character so
well and I just asked the questions he
filled in all the answers but he'd never
thought about those issues before and
even though you know he's dealing with
how would he react in this business
situation here just understanding which
lunch table he said in in high school
became really important in terms of
developing his character yeah it's kind
of like what I was taught by the guys in
my dad's generation you know even if you
never put it in the script knowing it
helps you and you know 90% in that of
that psychic bio I'm you know that psych
eval probably didn't make it into this
but knowing it makes you more
comfortable and gives you more the more
you know the more you can write it's
that simple the the other sort of
addendum I would put on this see I used
an academic do is legal term legal
Spiegel that's a Jewish lawyers term so
the other thing I would say about that
is that the great thing for some people
about working in
is not only do they know what they're
good at they learn to get good at other
things so there's another position in
the room that people don't talk about
much which is the line editor somebody
who's really good at going line for line
and going we could do a better job on
that dialogue that dialogue is not funny
or it's not and then the joke writer can
come up with so it's really a vault in I
think that's the way Haley and showman
described it in the book it's when when
we interviewed Leonard Stern he showed
us a book he'd written called a Martian
wouldn't say that yeah my dad's in it
and again it's this idea that you know
these characters so well that when you
hear a line you just say no no he would
never say that but that but when you've
written a book about a Martian you start
knowing the way he would say things that
wouldn't yeah these people in the room
know the characters so well that
everything comes through you feel their
language and and that's the other thing
the corollary to what Peter was saying
earlier corollary another nice word is
yeah it does educating you mr. Slocum
doesn't matter who you know on the in
the room and how close friends you are
if you don't get the show and you
haven't studied it you're not gonna last
that that you know it's not a most show
runners Phil is an exception I think Bob
Myers an exception where they will bring
people along but these days there's so
much at stake and there's so many shows
they don't have time to teach people now
my two former students who are on who
are on this new Hispanic version that
Norman Lear is there every day one day
at a time
93 and still mine totally intact and
he's there but she is mentoring these
two young writers and I think it's great
you know she's in her mid-40s and she's
mentoring these two young writers and
they're very fortunate that doesn't
always happen and so they've been when I
talked to them which is frequently
they'll say we don't mind that we're
getting less money to work on Netflix
because we're getting in it's like going
to grad school you know
and but it also says something about
your attitude as a writer if you haven't
studied the characters enough so that
you would suggest something that's out
of character so you would say something
is out of character in it and a lot of
people like someone once told me many
years ago that I should write a a
honeymooner spec this is still when they
were looking at specs now they want to
see pilots first of them maybe let you
know four samples that I should write a
Honeymooners as if it was like 2005 I
think it was some pitch that and I said
no I'm not gonna do that because nobody
could write those shows nobody knows the
honeymooners anymore and also it's a
honeymooners dates a little because you
know he was always me you can't say you
know to the moon Alice yeah that to say
just to go back for a second to the to
the business of the I'm blanking on the
word again nor French franchise
franchise is Lucy had a franchise that
people you have to really study the show
to know and that was every week she got
into trouble because she tried to do
something does he didn't wanted to it
was never just going shopping or they
they'd stomp her she and Ethel stomp
grapes or or she went to work because
she wanted so badly to be an actress
and she went to work the veggie valet
you know it's the best one they ever did
and it was always hoisting herself on
around batard trying to get attention
but there always had to be that third
object that makes anything dramatic if
it's just characters in a room talking
we're not gonna follow you but and and
and and by the way conflict and argument
are not the same thing I could start an
argument with your wife right now about
her dress and sorry Peter I stole that
from you
that's not conflict and if she argues
but conflict is when something really
important is at stake even if it's a
small thing like I said what suitcase
and anybody can anybody can write an
argument it's like Neil Simon my
favorite Neil Simon quote is
everybody thinks they can write a play
you just write down what happened but
the real art is taking from all the
moments of your life of taking disparate
things and bringing them together but
which every set here was really
important okay get it when he's off his
meds he's like you know when I'm off my
meds
it's dangerous day he needs a little
adolescent each stroke doesn't help but
Sir the we define I'll go back to what I
said it's really important competition
is defined as having a scarcity of
resources so that's really what
Geoffrey's saying is the essence of
conflict that you're trying to get
something and somebody else wants it and
you're battling over it so just
disagreeing is not conflict and I would
also quote a wonderful writer who bill
boyars I think was his name he wrote
mostly comedic westerns he wrote those
James Garner movies that were so great
I've forgotten his last name but he
wrote like you know support your local
sheriff support your local gunfire so he
was an action comedic writer and he said
life I'm sure other people have said it
too but he said
drama is life with all the boring parts
cut out oh it's kind of like the John
Lennon yeah you know life is what
happens while more light said the same
thing you said Oh
Elmore Leonard said I I don't write the
parts the people don't like to read
right and it really nicely I played
hooky from school today this is a good
day from oh you did would you I don't
teach on Tuesday stuff oh okay according
to his students exactly according to my
students I don't teach any exactly I'm
hoping this is a non evaluative question
loving these terms by the way they're
all Peter I have no clue what he's I
don't have any more clue than you do
what Kelly stuff how does a writer step
on their own laughs Peter you're the
comedy maven well I'm the easiest way to
do that is with poor editing
I'll give you an example let me tell you
a joke
man's dog dies so he takes it to a
Protestant minister and says would you
permit me to bury my dog here on the
grounds of the church he says no that's
that that's terrible it's blasphemous so
it takes them a carcass down to the
local rabbi and says could we bury him
on the grounds of the synagogue no
that's heresy get out of here takes them
down to a Catholic priest could I bury
my dog here and no absolutely not
gosh that's too bad I was going to
donate 40 thousand dollars to any place
that would let me bury the dog says all
well why didn't you tell me the dog was
Catholic okay bad joke but that's not
the point
so now let's say I gave you the same
punch but I said oh the dog was Catholic
why didn't you tell me sooner
now that sounds like same thing doesn't
it sure but it's not because what's the
reveal what's the key word in that joke
why didn't you tell me the dog was
Catholic and as soon as you hear that
you laugh but if I say oh the dog was
Catholic why didn't you tell me sooner
that part's not funny but when you have
the urge to laugh at Catholic I've
stopped you because you think oh there's
a punch but it's something even better
coming but I've screwed myself because I
didn't give you a chance and I went on
thinking making you think there's
something better to hold off and now the
moments gone so it's almost it could
it's the rewording it's it's stepping on
the reveal and not giving them time to
laugh appropriately and I think that
lesson is true in and you can change the
order of the religions I think that's
true in the end of scenes too I mean all
scenes need to have a button and in
comedy it very often is a comedic button
but it's not always a comedic button but
it the scene needs to be buttoned up
just like a joke needs to be buttoned up
and so if you go past it without
including any audience will feel you
step depth on the moment and you will
make the audience unconsciously annoyed
at you and or at the very least they
won't get the joke
well or they won't have responded when
you want him to because you've made them
think there was something coming when
there wasn't so you've led them on in a
way and it's called stepping on your
laps exactly as you said it that was an
easy one and we're back so when did the
interesting question start oh right now
actually this is but this one's a little
bit leading and this one is why are so
many screenwriters opposed to structure
I I didn't know they were my experience
is my experience is that there are there
are two groups of screenwriters now it
used to be I mean you probably remember
in the 90s and the early 2000s there was
the Chris Vogler book which is pretty
good actually
and then the true B book and who's the
guy that charges almost as much as the S
seminars I'm not gonna mention this name
there used to be like this is how you
write a screenplay and I think that
particularly in TV screen plays and
teleplays that's that's changing I would
like it again to me structure will
automatically is the easiest thing to
learn that's that's the craft if that's
not even to me the craft of it I could
basically teach anybody how to structure
a screenplay and I'm not and I'm lucky
to have Peter cuz he's really I'm not
joking around now he's really good at
structure but I believe structure comes
out of character in conflict so I have
not run up against a lot of writers who
are opposed to that I just think a lot
what some teachers do is they teach
structure Oh before they'll teach
character and conflict which is a big
mistake because it'll be an I've read
things that are beautifully structured
and empty their software now you can get
to structure your screenplay Marriner
makes a whole bunch of software programs
that's easy I could teach you that in
formatting and structuring in a week but
I hadn't heard what you what you're
hearing are you hearing that a lot of
people are opposed destruction
it was a question Oh see what your
answer was just throwing it out there
funny because I hear the opposite I hear
people fall back on structure there are
not so much TV I guess they're a bunch
of really funny videos on YouTube of
fake pitches have you seen them no and
brilliant they're hysterical there's a
wonderful one on there pitching Citizen
Kane it isn't caracal and with the wind
but there's I'm trying to think of the
one that I really love cuz we're talking
about structure here Pulp Fiction oh and
you get splaining you know these these
pages are all out of order don't worry
we made the story flow in a logical
sequence now and so I mean I think again
like many other areas that the concept
of structure is evolving also and but
that started a long time ago that price
started in the 60s with the new French
novel and stuff where all of a sudden
you don't know if you're seeing a
sequence or are you seeing a composite
or if you're how which part is fantasy
and somebody's head and which part is
real and so the whole notion of
structure has been evolving a lot so
things aren't necessarily as linear as
they were people are taking a lot bigger
liberties that way which is a good thing
I think you have to write the way that
no not talking about being in a room
then you've got to observe the rules
that the showrunner lays out but if
you're writing something of your own and
if for example I always tell students
and I tell myself that if you are
awakened at 3 o'clock in the morning and
a scene comes to you get up and write it
down and don't worry about where it goes
in the structure because if you wait you
might still be able to write the scene
but it won't have the power and the
passion you felt woke you up for a
reason and a lot of writers particularly
students are afraid to do that because
they've had pounded into their head that
you must write everything in order and
that's the more that makes me crazy the
writing things in order how can you know
there's a famous quote
how could I forget who said it I'm
blanking on everything today but I do
know franchise now I'm not gonna forget
that that how do I know what I think
till I see what I say oh powerful is
this what Adam is got above his desk
yeah is that good you got a new quality
for him I mean I think that a lot of
people are afraid to just dive into that
I am it's hard to just dive into that
darkness and then let it be bad and find
the structure but make sure that you
find it from the characters because
otherwise it'll be empty do you find
certain students or people that you've
worked with are okay going to those
places and others are really whether
it's their upbringing are fair skinned
nobodies okay with no one so to get them
to be okay with it
and what I did in my I'm teaching I
created I co-created of course a couple
of years ago a remade course for
freshmen and it was the first day of
class a week be a week tomorrow and I
said to everybody in the room get ready
to embrace shit are you gonna have to
erase that no okay so it's the Anne
Lamott dictum from bird by birth you
have an obligation to be shitty oh you
know which um you should you can almost
see the the weight come off their show
that's the most is the closest I feel of
being like a therapist because I'm
releasing them from the need to be good
and they can write because then I say
that because you're going to be anyway
you're 18 years old how good are you
going to be and I don't give you a good
grade for being good and then they go
wait a minute if we try to be good
you're not gonna grade us better than
people who try to be bad exactly because
I don't care I'm interested in the
process not the product you're 18
doesn't matter how good it is it's still
gonna suck you know that word we can't
use I'm sorry I'm sorry
18 yes this is a very big thing with me
this this need people have and I think
it's because I
and I'll always be a recovering
perfectionist that that it's another
thing the partnership has given me
because he forces me to put it down and
you know if I if I had if I had my
druthers not so much anymore but I used
to be that we just take forever because
I didn't want to be bad yeah the P word
is a synonym for scared yeah exactly
oh I see right right uh-huh I'm afraid
it'll suck and if you tell students at
the beginning it's okay to suck it's
okay to be bad you it's like Peter said
earlier then you have something that's
on paper you can play with it forever
but if you don't put it down you got
nothing you were talking this morning
about a guy who's been working for five
years in the screenplay
five ten ten five I could except you
know it's not like he's writing the
Great American Novel he's writing a
screenplay come on really
well unless he's so lost in the process
because they should be writing three
screenplays not one double-spaced 12
pages a year output the night oh no I I
think I think that it is just fear you
know and older people can have fear too
sure because then yeah I think it's it's
okay to be young and to fail and make
mistakes and with older people we have
two worst days of my life for the days
that I finish a play or I finished
something and I my first reader is
always my wife because she's an actress
and she'll say nice things and then
she'll say so basically what you're
asking me to do is put marbles in my
mouth to say these lines you know and
it's and after I get over being hurt and
thinking about divorce court and all of
those things I you know she's right
again we're writing for actors we're not
writing
yes producers have to read it executives
have to read it but you're gonna be
replaced really fast if you can't write
dialogue said Claude Rains in Casablanca
says to tip Bogart he says what what
brought you to Gaza Blanca and Bogart
says the waters and and Claude Rains
it's a desert and Booker says something
like I was mistaken I was misinformed I
was missing which is great dialogue just
great dialogue music it's music you know
which is the difference between speak
like we're doing here
and an interesting dial and an
interesting data but you said earlier
that when you're right you're you said
earlier when your wife reads your first
draft or second draft that you know
she's an actress so in you're
essentially writing for actors how does
a writer write for what they think
people will say versus what actors oh
just years of practice and listening to
readings I find readings incredibly
valuable workshopping
and films and TV should be done the same
way actors are not shy about telling you
what doesn't work for them just like
singers are not shy about telling a
songwriter hey you know when I land on
that it doesn't go the words don't go
with the notes sort of a simple answer
to your question though is read your
dialog aloud yes very good point and I
don't looking for that you can start
using a world that that's not coming off
my tongue very easily I don't think I
want to ask somebody to say that you
know when composers compose and you're
writing for an orchestra and you don't
know how to play the French horn and you
can't play the oboe and quite often
after it's done you have people play
through the parts and they say that's
unplayable you can't finger it that way
and they have to go back and they have
to change their parts because they're
not writing for that instrument you know
they think about drama in any form is
what actions are playable what and
they're not playable so what I've
learned in the course of my writing life
and of watching other people's work is
is crying the woman cries that's not a
play you'll be more descriptive about it
what is she doing when she's crying that
the actors always gonna find something
else to do something better but you got
to give them a
you know actors hate two things more
than anything one to be told how to say
a line and to blocking because blocking
is the it's blocking is like structures
the easiest thing in the world to do it
all you do as a director is block you're
not much of a director actors like
directors who like I'm sure that's why
they love Tom as a director because he's
also been an actor and so he knows how
actors think you know and so what I
would but I think it's really just
experience in writing a lot and and
really get allowed and and getting other
people to read it one true there are
tricks that you can use in stage
dialogue one is people don't typically
talk people typically don't you know in
real life people don't say you may not
go there you cannot go you can right
away hear that that sounds but you know
if you think about it if you're sitting
in a room with an actor they're noticing
things about people you're not noticing
and they're looking for mannerisms
they're looking for expressions what are
they doing with their hands is
everything coming out monotone or is the
pitch going up or is it going down does
it go faster does it go slow they're
listening for all these things in the
same what differentiates this Texan from
this New Yorker and how are they
sounding so different and why is this
story working and this one is and why am
i captivated and listening this person
why is this person sound shallow so if
they ever have to sound shallow then
they know well if I'm kind of looking to
the side like this and I kind of talking
out inside of my mouth and on what words
would I be saying then they noticing and
good dialog writers also have really
good ears and they're listening for the
way people speak and and they remember
those sorts of things I'm a big believer
in riedel writers
rivals who is that like a character that
got cut out of Fiddler on the Roof what
is that I'm a big believer in in writers
notebooks I've been keeping them since I
was very young and I don't mean Diaries
I don't mean today I went to Peter
despereaux's house
in fun of me all day and was the same
thing every time you come say I don't
need to write that down because I'm
gonna remember it but I mean like not
sometimes I'll go months without putting
anything in but Lydia Davis who's a
wonderful writer said that what she
likes about keeping in a book and I
think this is really valuable advice is
is you're never really starting with a
blank page because you know is go to the
notebook and find something you wrote
and play with it and and if you're
blocked on one thing you go over there
and you you work you work on that and
maybe it doesn't go anywhere but maybe
it does and that's another thing that
writers have a hard time coming to terms
with that is sort of another corollary
to the figure is I want to use that word
a lot before I forget it but no I was
just gonna say that you have to get used
to things going into a corner and maybe
you have to leave it alone and go to
something else this goes back to what
Peter was saying about the guy that was
working on one script for 10 years
that's crazy because and
even if it wasn't a script that's crazy
you want to work on different things
because different days may call you to
something and you're not gonna get
anything done if you just work on one
thing but but this goes back again to
also to the idea of observation that
people people think for example that
objectivity in the world exists but it
doesn't if if three people walk into
this room would they all see the same
thing it's he chairs rug desk no if an
interior designer was to walk in this
room they would get nauseous if a
carpenter came in they'd be looking at
the shelves plumb if a psychologist came
in they'd be looking at the titles of
the books and if a chiropractor came in
they'd be looking at our posture and
saying I see money coming my way
slouching but the the eye doesn't tell
the brain what it sees the brain tells
the eyes what to look for and so the I
didn't know that and so actors are
constantly looking at when they're
seeing any extreme and
behavior they're paying attention to the
littlest things you know it's not just
that his voice raises but what's he
doing with his hands while he's doing it
how is this posture changed it's gonna
use that and so again the same thing
good writers when they hear people talk
they're saying did that person get
tongue-tied when she got really angry or
did this whole slew of stuff just come
rolling off the tongue and does this
sound like something she said a lot of
times or is this something that you know
is she saying it legato or staccato you
know it's like I'm so angry you I could
just bust or is it I'm so angry at you
all right could just bust and you all
these things they're listening for these
things saying wow listen how the
emotions coming out in everyday people
doing stuff that's the way I want to
write the dialogue so it's you look at
what you're interested in and if you're
a good dialogue writer you don't just
think of what words they're gonna say
it's what have I seen people do when
they're trying to demonstrate them when
they're demonstrating that emotion how
do the words come out we saw an
interesting interaction of somebody
steal someone's parking space and the
guy handled it pretty well he was
waiting patiently but he said something
to the woman but the woman was like you
know didn't give him the bird but she
basically told him where to go then she
turned around so just watching that
whole interaction was fascinating I mean
I it was like a TV show I couldn't
believe that she was a real character
but but again a great writer would have
listened to every word and how they got
strung together and how did how did she
express what words did she did she use
she said sorry you were too late but
again cut him off and then said he was
too late pretty much yeah yeah and again
I think in New York but the whole idea
of the body language when she said so
are you just too late was it you sorry
you're just too late now or was it sorry
you were just too late you know yeah but
I mean all of those things matter
right right subtext and and so again
it's if you're interested in that I mean
a lot of writers don't realize you know
they're so interested in story and you
know how whatever I doing that you know
and not to to end it instead of thinking
of how would this person express
themselves in this situation to make me
feel that I'm part of this scene so that
I could put myself in their place and
feel what they're doing through the
words I would just add that that that is
what drafting is for because in one
draft you're gonna be focused on the
story and then maybe when you've got the
story you're gonna look at word choice
and another draft and then you're gonna
look at the dialogue and you know really
polish the dialogue this is why you have
to disabuse young writers of the notion
that three drafts from their done I
don't know what draft do you want in
your novel now oh my god no but it's I
encourage that we're waiting that's why
I you know again if you took ten years
to write a novel I totally get that
right because novels are the heart
that's so hard
they don't have long agent Donna Tartt
who's an amazing writer shreds one novel
she publishes a novel every ten years
and but she's working her you know five
hundred pages and there's a lot and
that's how long your novel is five
hundred and I'm cutting a lot but the
thing is you again he has an advantage
because he's willing to put it down it's
not painful for him to put bad things on
paper which makes him really unlikable
in my opinion well that's not the only
reason no but I was just warning polite
when dimension of my unlike ability did
you see a little puppet up there a
little Freud puppet up there on the top
oh yes no patients hold it when they're
feeling antsy
no no no I go and I go if they're saying
why do you hate you whenever you're
ready
we're rolling yet so I went to this
evening once at the Paley Center it's
quite a number of years ago because
Larry Gelbart has sadly been gone for a
while
creator of the TV show mash in a billion
plays the book for funny thing happened
on the way to the forum
he and Mel Brooks who had first met on
Sid Caesar show shows in the 50s we're
doing an evening and a talk and then at
the end of the talk there was a Q&A as
there always is and a guy got up and he
said can you illustrate the difference
between a joke and wit and Mel Brooks
took a glass of water and poured it over
its his head and he said that's a joke
and there was a long pause and the guy
said soul
so what's wit then Larry Gelbart said
wit is dry it's a great long speaking of
which the structure of a joke versus the
structure of a screenplay similar
different well um can I tamper with the
question is short it a little pleased it
it's the way I'd like to see that
question is looking at the structure of
a joke and then how do you work it into
a screenplay okay because jokes jokes
have to meet two criteria to work in a
screenplay they have to either advance a
story or they have to and they have to
totally come out of character if they
don't meet those two criteria excise
them they're expendable you don't want
to keep them so that's always the rule
and I've seen writers with tears in
their eyes saying this is so funny I
hate to let this go but it's not coming
out of character it's not moving things
along I got a I got a dump it so you
have to have those two elements in there
is there a joke quota I mean all kidding
aside like do dues to be okay yeah I
don't think there is any more I mean I
hope there isn't there's two shows on
Netflix one's called the ranch and I
forget the the other one it just came on
it's with Kathy Bates and it's about a
woman who owns a pot store and they're
both like those sitcoms in the
80 some of which I wrote for where it
was like jump talk joke joke joke joke
joke joke joke joke joke joke joke oh
look you're wearing what was the one in
the ranch that I just thought oh this is
so old-fashioned where he's wearing Uggs
that this guy who used to be a football
players wearing Uggs and the parents are
everybody's making jokes about the uggs
it has nothing to do with the story they
just are looking for jokes to shooting
in front of a live audience and someone
told us this morning that those two
shows are not doing that great on
Netflix and it doesn't surprise me it's
really old-fashioned those are rule
three jokes a page when I started and
that could be and lots does the producer
would give you the joke one joke I had
to put in a script was a look at Barbie
Cantrell on a beach almost wearing that
bikini having nothing to do with the
story terrible joke they're not even
really a joke Elliott's showman told us
a really nice story said I was working
on Maude and Maude was a very
sophisticated comedy where everything
really jokes are very difficult to come
by because the characters weren't very
broad and he said we had our office
right across the hall from the island
wasn't on the family and he said the
characters there was so broad that you
could always get a joke if he needed it
so he said we'd be there till 7:00 or
8:00 every night and at 5 o'clock they
all left and they said if they needed a
joke they would take Archie Bunker and
they'd give him a malaprop's so he'd say
eat it I think I got a hernia I got to
see a grown ecologist and you'd have the
joke because he's just such an easy
character to write jokes for and if
again you know keep saying like my
favorite sitcom is still Big Bang and
those characters are so well drawn and
the characters have so many traits that
are identifiable that there's always a
joke when you need it there's always
something about one of the characters
that's going to fit
so whether it's a short joke or an OCD
joke or autism joke or a foreign
language joke
there's always something because the
characters have so many traits that you
can come out with jokes about anything
to add no I'm not really a very good
joke writer I've never been I my humor
comes out of but he's a very good joke
critic when we talk i mean jokes have
never been my strengths
you know characters I've written them
and I've written but they'll usually
come out of what a character's doing is
so I wouldn't really consider them the
kind of jokes that Peters talking about
I I love jokes
I don't like joke jokes and I studied
with with with Danny Simon who said
never set up a straight line to
accommodate a punch line and I and
that's what kind of annoyed me about the
ranch because that's what it did all
these wonderful actors in it and instead
of using them to develop character they
were just giving them joke after joke
after joke and it just seemed kind of
old-fashioned to me well you know when
you decide much coming to write the joke
it's not a good joke you know there's an
old saying in boxing you never see the
punch that knocks you out that should
work for jokes as well but I think that
you know again to go back to where we
started with this with jokes versus wit
I think you know one of my one of my
biggest influences is an old coward no
Karen did not write jokes an old coward
wrote situations that were inherently
funny
to people who are on their second
honeymoon who go out on their respective
balconies in the South of France and who
do they run into but their ex-spouses
and everybody has stolen that situation
private lives was the play and but at
the time it was kind of risque and of
course what are they gonna do they're
gonna fall back in love and fight and
breakup and get married and break up and
get married and that was the that was
the premise but you can see that really
witty stuff would come out of that but
very few jokes I think he had you know
he had jokes like
I'm gonna butcher this but it was like
and it cuz one of them had been on a
trip how was Egypt very very dry you
know no that's not a joke that's what
you know and and how were the plains of
Spain very very wet you know that kind
of thing that's not really joke writing
Peters talking about constructed jokes
if you say there is a but what's nice
about that and I'd push it a little but
but the the nice thing in the no coward
example is there's a rhythm just like it
a joke there's a set up on a payoff you
know if you say very very wet and you
don't say very very dry people will
unconsciously be waiting for it and if
they don't hear it they'll be
disappointed they mean I don't know why
one of the one of the movies that works
great for me is is the first and the
second Back to the Future because
everything by the way this is what
structure is oh I'm glad I got a new
question
oh please do yeah well and this comes a
lot from my my childhood of my training
my my dad and his friends always said
all structure really is is set up and
pay off some things you set up and pay
off quickly some things you set up
halfway through a script and pay it off
later but if you set up something and
don't pay it off people are going to
notice that the film or the play was
missing something's missing
so really people for a long time I've
overcomplicated the idea of structure
really all it comes down to is setting
up and paying off if you don't do that
you don't have something properly
structured so I give a lot of set up is
all conflict for example I set up the
mother moving in with her daughter and
then I don't pay off that something bad
funny or good funny is gonna happen I
haven't written a whole premise I
haven't written the whole they'll get
along well it's really boring right well
nice the two of them has a light thing
else as opposed to well Charlie Peters
has Oh
said I mean I general he's an old friend
of mine but he's always said there's
like one of the hardest things to
explain to students charlie taught at
USC for many years and for us briefly
but he said the hardest thing to explain
to a student is because in life we all
want to get along we don't want conflict
we want to have a nice easy but that
makes for a dull drama he gave us a
great quote in the book he said the hero
of every of every movie wants the script
end on page 2 right
Jack Black does not want to go to Skull
Island and find King Kong that's the
last thing he wants to do what were you
gonna say about back to the future oh oh
yes short-term memory loss is a bitch
right that everything they do in Back to
the Future everything they set up
everything and this and they went
through like 20 drafts before they shot
everything they do is paid off
everything so you feel really satisfied
when you come out of that movie you may
not know why every joke they set up is
paying off no loose ends
yeah and that's really great writing and
so and you're waiting for the sequel
because he at the end of the movie he's
like where we're going he takes the
stinking badges line from what's the
famous movie the pyramid ray Sierra
Madre roads he says what about Bette
you're backing up well you know weird
what about roses roads where we're going
we don't need no stinking rose and it's
right out of another movie and and set
you up for the you want you have to see
that sequel now but the third one there
I don't watch that this is the Western
that's not very good
what are five things a writer should
know about the TV writing room um you
take two and a half and I'll take a head
you want me to start
yeah please know that to get in you 90%
chance you're gonna have to work your
way into the room as a as the script
sistent as a writer's assistant those
jobs are plentiful and they're great and
you will get training and know that it
will take a while also know that when
you're a baby writer don't talk listen
nobody likes someone who answers
questions know that most people are good
at one or two things but nobody's good
at everything I think I answered three
that Lee and don't be the smartest
person in the room never ever first ever
why because everybody will hate you and
actually will show runner and you won't
be the smartest person in the room and
everybody will see that and really you
cannot be full of yourself in the room
I'm not gonna mention the show and I'm
not gonna mention I will mention that it
was my friend Bob who who is very close
as I said to chuck lorre who gave Chuck
Lorre his break and Chuck will call him
every once in a while even though bob is
semi-retired he'll call him up and say I
really did help but it was a point a
couple years ago when he had five shows
on the air and he went on one of the
shows and he pitched a joke and he said
to Bob was that funny when you were
working on my two dads was that funny
back then facts of life he was just and
Chuck and and Bob went to Chuck and he
said I don't need the money I'm out of
here
and he left you know if you're a
showrunner the best kind of showrunner
you could be as somebody who mentors
other people who secure enough like Phil
Rosenthal to really care about getting
the best out of people that's the method
on a leader anyway we had a lot of great
stories about rooms and showrunners and
Peter Casey was great he said I worked
on The Jeffersons and I came to to the
room late one day and I hadn't eaten
breakfast so I brought a little box of
cornflakes with me and I went to the
corner where the coffee was poured it in
and took a little of the cream put it on
there and the guy said that's not for
your cereal that's for the coffee and he
charged him like 25 cents for doing that
oh and he said they would now feed us
the worst food ever and he said when I
went to work on Cheers with the Charles
brothers they would take us out to
really good restaurants or if they had
to work really late they would call up
one of the really good restaurants and
we'd order from their menu and they
would deliver it
he said they treated the writers with so
much kindness and respect he said and
they got such great work at Hearst
nobody complained if it was late we're
with the Jeffersons like everybody was
grumbling all the time and hated being
in the room so he said the Charles
brothers made his Perla kittens
how's it you actually said that but I'm
taking license okay
was there one other I think you only got
one in that's four altogether four so
five total any five be careful be
careful
oh yeah no were the exit well I know
what you're sort of this is sort of
repetitious but I think it bears
repeating it's really important that
when you get into a room you use it as a
learning experience because you're one
of very few people when I started there
was still a freelance market there
really is no freelance Markum anymore
and so if you have the luck to get into
a room take advantage of it and be
humble and Peter's right but I will add
a fifth just for the sake of
completeness that every room has a
culture oh that's and you want to spend
a lot of time observing before you jump
in and just because one person makes a
joke doesn't mean everybody makes jokes
and if one person kids another person
that doesn't mean everybody teases and
you want to wait and when you really
understand how people interact then you
slowly test the water and start to do it
come on even then you do it slowly my
two wonderful former students who are on
one day at a time we're on the show now
they're in their second season they're
not the baby writers anymore you see how
that works so they were
on the show they were on like three
months they were on like show seven or
eight and they hadn't said that much I
mean they've done their work they were
the first script their mentor wrote with
them so it was the three of them writing
it which was really generous of her that
doesn't know what's happened and she one
of them told me that they didn't say
anything one day and one of the one of
the writers said Caroline we'd really
like to hear what you guys think you
guys are these characters ain't is one
of these characters age opening and yet
she said she began by in the old what if
thing so that she left room to be wrong
if they didn't like what she said and
she said they were after that day they
were like you guys whenever you have
something to say say it don't be shy but
they were smart to wait because they
were learning they were observing and
they were only 25 years old that's young
to be in a room so and they didn't think
the show was gonna get a second season
and now it's big heads and
emmy-nominated it's you know it's a big
it and by the way you tricked us you
said only three more questions and the
first one is a five partner don't think
that went past us it went past me you
make her laugh yeah she has a low
threshold the penultimate question this
is a lot of pressure it's a good thing
she's adorable right you know that we're
judging your questions right that's okay
and I'm not judging
I'm at peace with that because I'm not
did you have enough carrot juice to make
you at peace Oh two references to carrot
juice what are some see another multiple
partner what are some go ahead what are
what are some of the most important
questions a screenwriter can ask
themselves when developing a story idea
how much is it
ten points reach that doesn't get you to
a hundred no I think one one important
question is how Universal is it and you
know you may be having the most esoteric
story but if it touches everybody it's a
universal story if it's very very narrow
then and it doesn't and so you're always
saying how are people going to relate to
this can anybody find something in this
relationship I'm creating in this
conflict that I'm creating that they
recognize something and hence that's why
you asked the the mother-daughter
premise for the book because you figured
most people can relate well this is a
generic old old premise starting with my
sister I'd Lois everybody has had a
mother yeah I think I think I think it
was it was chosen because you could I
don't know your background because you
could do your teacher oh she's a child
of a single mother she told us that
you'd been listening I have a slightly
different take on that I I believe in
the Stephen Sondheim dictum that the
more personal a story is and I don't
mean by that autobiographical then the
more it matters to you the more
universal it's gonna be and but both
things are valid it depends on the
writer I will tell you that if you try
to write something commercial you will
fail every time out for example when
diehard was a success there was one
there was one movie after another that
came out with that kind of you know none
of them were as good as diehard and and
then but but for every movie that came
out like that
you know hero in a in a trap place
trying to save the world whatever it is
where the sense of humor yeah with us
that's very important there were
hundreds of scripts that were written
that never saw the light of anywhere so
I I believe that you have to write what
you want to write and
look at what go ahead make my day did
you know everybody tried to come out
with that and that wasn't a new concept
when when they when it was written I
mean the bullet I was a bullet worked
same kind of idea bullet was a more
stylish cop but the Dirty Harry movies
are great they're really well made
they're kind of the detective version of
the spaghetti westerns you know but
having that one cool line yeah key
moment but today I don't think one cool
line is gonna make a great movie why I
think it was also the right actor for
the right time for the late sixties you
know but I think the other thing you
need is patience well all the things
we've been talking about today the the
ability to tolerate what ambiguity he
likes that word because nobody else
understands to tolerate failure to
tolerate having to get up and try again
the next day
no no writing career can ever be made on
one script I don't there you know I
really believe that you've got to write
a lot and not judge it those are all
things we've talked about all this
before but yes those are the things and
then of course being willing to show you
work not waiting to show you work if
you're just gonna put your work in a
drawer and you're just doing it for your
own pleasure well that's fine but then
don't say you want to be a professional
writer I'm waiting for the 19th part
last question well there was a follow-up
okay the follow-up is penultimate point
two you said that most films could be
based on or or the popularity could be
based on one line like I'm paraphrasing
but go ahead and remember or yeah the
hook or you know frankly my dear I don't
give a damn something like that but yeah
but that had nothing to do with the plot
of the movie that was just that was
character that's just character right
but you don't feel that today could be
well you still they want a hook before
they want to hear the
before they want to hear the story so we
used in something we're working on now
we used back to the future you know the
hook would be a young boy goes back in
time to prevent him to make sure his
parents get married so he'll continue to
exist I mean that's terrible I can't
remember what we used that's a hook
that's not a premise yet it's an idea
for so to me a hook is it's it's an idea
for a story you know and you know it's
not yet you still haven't developed the
story the thing you brought in earlier
about the two brothers is much more
developed than that
but in terms of a line sort of living on
past the film Oh LaVon yes the film are
we beyond that no I don't hope that
we're beyond that be beyond that I mean
you gotta you get memorable lines as
recently as When Harry Met Sally what's
the line you remember I'll have what
she's a CLE you know that line was
improved it wasn't even a scripted line
that was Rob Reiner's mom that's Carl
writers wife but it wasn't that from the
90s yeah I mean so I mean anything yes
there's one in a recent movie that I
don't know have you guys seen get out
yet not yet great writers are always
trying to write those lines yeah but
they're usually really self-conscious
and awkward this wasn't because this is
a movie the only thing I can tell you
about the movie it made it you know it
was made for nothing and the guy was
famous before he made it the directors
appeal and it's wonderful he had that
show on Comedy Central and he knows
everybody and but this is his first
directors directorial debut and the
movie wasn't expected to do well and is
one of the most successful movies of the
year
and there's a great line in that I think
will live on past the movie and that's
the premise of the movie is a white girl
takes her black boyfriend to meet the
parents that's not what the movies about
at all but that's all
tell you a little ruin the movie for you
but the father the first thing the
father says to the to the black
boyfriend is actually played to my
wife's confirmation by a British actor
he says you know I would have voted for
Obama for a third term now that line is
brilliant it's also in character it has
to do with the movie but it's so witty
and it's so true that that like liberals
like embarrassed liberals you know when
they want to say something good in there
around black it's part of what the
movies about that he that people will I
mean he said in an interview that he
gets that all the time from white
liberals that you know well wish that I
could have he could have had a third
term you know but they're trying to show
you how liberal they are so yes I think
that I think Peters right I think we'll
always have those just like well oh is
it a Paris but it's just it's just bad
when you see it self-consciously written
like I think I just written that line
yeah well you know hopefully you're good
enough writer to see that and take it
out you know did the other thing that
really bugs me and in writing is when
the writer makes a reference that
obviously doesn't belong in the period
or they're trying to be too contemporary
you know to contemporaneous they're
trying to be too hip you know so they'll
make a joke about something that nobody
would have made a joke about you know I
see that all the time I probably done it
many times but again a great line is
great it's great for advertising if it
doesn't make a great movie you know
Bruce there's so many lines in die hard
but that's not why the movie was
successful I have a theory about why
that movie was unique and successful he
wasn't there to save the world he was
there to get his wife out of the
building and that's what made it human
you know and and a lot of these like
speed which was a big success which
followed it was such a contrived
situation you know a bust that if it
goes below you know a certain you know
it'll blow up I mean
come on and then they manipulate you by
having the old trick which is
everybody's used of having the partner
killed which raises the stakes which can
work it worked great for oh come on help
me out
Lillian Hellman's boyfriend who was
blacklisted you know a great mystery
writer well it's been used in a zillion
movie yeah but who was it he was the guy
who did it better than anybody in the
movie about the bird some like you know
where there was something in the the
stuff that dreams are made of as a
classic line that will always will
always know that's from Maltese Falcon
oh okay what line was it yeah it's the
stuff that you know when he sees what's
inside the birds you know it's the
stones or whatever it is he says he's
you know it's the it's the thing
everybody's the MacGuffin that
everybody's been looking for he says the
stuff that dreams are made of that's
great right and and then the other line
in that movie that I love is I'm not
going over for your sweetheart meeting
I'm not going to jail for you I love
that movie it's so well written Dashiell
Hammett thank you for helping me so much
was there for you
you